[Music]
i am 31 but i have cerebral palsy i walk
independently with no assistant devices
or anything like that when it comes to
dating because i just don't feel like
i'm the one someone's going to choose i
sabotage it before it even starts
oh he doesn't like me yeah
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show
so glad that you're with us it's the
best mental health show of all time
my friends tell me that i speak mostly
in hyperbole and so there's probably
some truth to that too some some and i
hope you're doing so well if you want to
be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
and man i'll do the best i can we'll try
to figure it out all right hey
in the great news
dude i'm excited to announce we've got
five
five new
editions of questions for humans cards
coming we have several down down the
we're releasing them in in segments here
so uh we got five new ones coming and
then we're gonna have a few more that we
release um towards the end of the summer
for teachers and for workplace stuff and
then we're gonna have the delony after
dark questions about sex and intimacy
they're gonna be coming out about around
christmas but the five new ones we got
coming out awesome oh this one workplace
edition
um dating edition so we had one that was
for couples that have been married and
seeing each other for a while this one
is hey we are taking our relationship to
the next level we're no longer just
going to be internet
um hey how are you doing we're actually
going to meet in person and so this is
dating edition um there's a guy's night
and a girls night i was not a fan of
this
it y'all were
and the questions hey we just want to go
have girls night and we want to have
take a deck with us we want to have um
just a bunch of dudes getting together
and we want to have auditions and i was
like man friends are friends or friends
and the number of times i've gone out
when it's just men and women is is
outnumbered i think the times when it's
just been the bros
um
but y'all kept asking like no no we want
girls night questions we want guys
nights so just so you all know
we did get some extraordinary brilliant
women of of across age ranges to pitch
in on this so it's not just a group of
dudes who sat in a room it was not just
from my head like i don't i don't i
don't know so anyway
girls night edition guys not edition and
then parents and teens that was another
one that we got a lot of requests for um
i'm staring at my teenager and they have
morphed into
an alien and i don't know what to do
next and so we got those for you
workplace dating edition girls night out
guys night out parents and teens
go to johndaloni.com
humans and they start june 20th i'm dude
i'm so excited about these
it's so small it's so little
the the question the cards that have
been out there
and when i say little like there's no
tech there's no nothing fancy
the number of people who've written in
moms dads co-workers um romantic
partners who you name it grandparents
who said this just gave me an avenue
into the hearts and minds of those that
i love or it helped us in an awkward
situation or we laughed so hard or we
cried so hard
um i found out things about my wife that
i i mean i've been with her 25 years and
i found things out about her that i
didn't know just from these cars so man
pick them up johndeloney.com
humans i'm excited about it man it's
been fun all right let's go to sherry in
brooktondale new york what's up sherry
hi dr zolone what are you up to um
work
what kind of work do you do
i'm i'm a registered nurse
oh you've had a boring few years
yeah right
how are you for real
good good
good good that's tough that's tough
tough tough and in new york nonetheless
good grief yeah
geez all right so what's up how can i
help
so
my my question or concern is i have um i
i'm naturally an anxious person um but
when i'm in a vehicle
with somebody else especially as a
passenger
um my anxiety is through the roof
um
natural you know back roads i do fine
with
um but high traffic situations
um
you know stopping
like when there's a lot of traffic
around traffic lights um the highway is
the worst
um
even with my husbands we've been married
for
almost
um i think 27 years and my anxiety i
used to be pretty cool about things and
it's just gotten it's terrible the last
couple years
did something did something happen to
set it off
no
i mean not not really maybe i'm going to
say 20 years ago
i
i was following somebody a friend and i
were you know in a vehicle and
um
she had pointed out to me that the car
in front of us was swerving a little bit
and the car actually in front of me went
over a yellow line and was hit head-on
by a
tractor-trailer and then the
tractor-trailer came in front of me yep
um so i luckily i had backed off or i
think i would have we would have been
you know in that accident
um okay so you're just telling me that
yep does your heart start beating faster
yeah i could your voice changed a little
bit
oh okay
when you talk about that story you tell
somebody that story you remember that
story
yes yeah pretty much deep detail for
detail you can feel it on you right
yeah okay all right so yep then all of a
sudden the last couple of years this
pops up um is this getting into the way
of your life i know that sounds like a
dumb question but i mean you could just
a simple answer would be well just don't
drive on the highway um tell me where
this is getting involved this is messing
your life up a little bit
it is it is my husband and i are to the
point now where
we're arguing in the car and he's like
and he's a he's a school bus driver so
he's
he does this for a living oh there's
nothing
nothing that husbands like more
um when they have they're good at like
two things in the world
and their wife is like you know what you
should be doing
yes listen husband's willing to tell him
what to do turn here look here look out
for that card
don't do that
i know it's really bad and then my my
boys i have two sons who
you know i
was helping them with their getting
their driver's license and so i was
often in the back seat because i'm the
obnoxious worried mom um and i tried my
best to keep my mouth shut but still so
literally
driver
yes i i am no matter who
no matter who who it is
and i'm not saying this to shame you i'm
saying this just as a fact
that creates then
how many boys you got
i have two okay
that creates a legacy of anxious drivers
that they will then pass on to do you
see how that goes
yep right and i know you know that i
know that's one of the reasons why you
want to
so two two big things here
um
i'll start off with a question that i
always ask people who are wrestling with
um intense anxiety like this especially
one that's escalating
um that's seemingly getting worse over
time okay
and this sounds like a i'm making fun of
you with this question and i'm not i'm
deeply serious about this question and i
think it's where every single person
struggling with anxiety should start
and that is
do you want to be free of this
or is this serving a purpose in your
life that you want to hang on to
no there's there's no purpose it needs
to it needs to go okay okay it needs to
go sometimes when somebody uh maybe
they've been assaulted or um they've got
some sort of existential fear about
being alone with with a a man right
they'll tell me when they're in the
presence of any man
good guys neutral guys guys they've
never met their bodies
sounds the alarms right their heart
starts beating a little bit faster their
hands get clammy they get that warmth in
their stomach that that fear response
kicks up
and they don't want to let that go
because there's this perception that
that's keeping me safe it's not but it
feels like a defense like a protective
layer that i don't want to give up and
so i always ask people uh and that's you
can extrapolate that across anything um
i always ask do you want this to be done
so you want to be you want you want this
completely done with you want to be able
to hop in a car drive on the highway
ride on the highway kick your feet up
laugh
absolutely yes that is what i want okay
so um here's two two ways we're gonna
approach this this isn't every situation
but this is your situation i think this
is a great place for most people to
start um first is you have an acute
situation
you were almost killed in
in a car on the highway
okay
and so
the word i use there is ownership you
have to own that almost happened to you
you have to own that when you get on a
highway
you are turning over your life to
thousands of other strangers going in
the same direction opposite directions
for you in any one of them can move
their wheel one inch
and kill you
you have to just own that yeah and it
almost happened to you right
yep so a big thing about our anxiety is
it builds this big fake wall in front of
reality
and so one of the cornerstones of
getting well from anxiety is saying this
could happen
and for you it almost did and your body
put a gps pin you know when you tell
somebody where to be in that little it's
almost a heart shape but it's not quite
it's a little gps pin your body put a
pin in that
and said this situation is not safe
just as though
ten thousand years ago you were walking
through the woods and you saw bear
cha-cha on the ground and your body put
a pin in that and said this area is not
safe because this is where the bears are
let's go find food somewhere else same
same neurological mechanism at work here
it put a pen in highways and said not
safe
but life happens and we are really good
at coming up with distractions and duct
tape and figuring out other ways to get
through life so
we get angry we get raged out we white
knuckle it we have another drink another
drink we cheat we come up with
distractions for ourselves and we can
distract ourselves for five years ten
years fifteen twenty years and then
what'd you say your job was you're a
nurse
yeah yeah the last two years have been
utter hell right
oh for for sure and i drive i drive a
lot i'm i work with you know um
developmentally disabled people in group
homes and i have to drive a long ways to
get to my
work okay
so what you have
is a
you've heard of the phrase secondary
traumatic stress
yep you live in other people's pain for
a living that's what you do you provide
you provide hope and light and
connectivity to people in the darkest
moments people who are alone and
isolated with disabilities
that's what you do and you do that over
time and your body begins to shift how
it sees the world that everything is
pretty dark and pretty messy and then
you throw a pandemic in on top of it and
the normal things that keep us well and
whole like human connection like
exercise like sunlight like good sleep
suddenly goes away
and
all anxiety is is an alarm system
letting you know that you're not safe
you're disconnected or you're in a
situation where you can't control and
quite honestly when you're on the
highway
we're as safe as we could be driving
down the highway in two thousand pound
metal boxes at seven or eighty miles an
hour
there is little control we have over
what our neighbors are gonna do on the
roads we can only control ourselves
and so two out of the three things there
are already on the table for our little
primitive brains that are trying to
adapt from riding a horse to suddenly
driving down the road in a volkswagen
right
so when the rest of your coping
mechanisms have gotten thin over the
last few years it doesn't surprise me in
the least in fact it makes perfect sense
that the alarms about the highway have
gotten louder and louder and louder
that's just a distraction from
the what the broader picture which is
you're not you're not okay
you're tired
you're exhausted
your relationships are
messy and my guess is you got teenage
boys now is that right
uh one's 22 and the other is 19. oh see
now you're starting to have pictures of
your life when they're not in them
and they're going off to do their things
right
and yeah it was very hard when they
first got their licenses very hard but
it's hard because you lose that sense of
control right now they're off in the
world but also it's a transition my
little boy's growing up
and that means my life is gonna be
different
see what i'm saying
like it shifts and so what your body's
feeling is this ultimate everything's
starting to move on us the boys are
going to college they're going to move
away i'm going to have to look at this
husband of mine and go ugh
what are we going to do now and he's
just a bus driver and you're like turn
left turn right and we're going to have
to figure out who we are and so here's
what i want you to do i want you to do
two important things moving forward okay
yeah this is going to sound ridiculous
actually three all right three things
first one is
i want you to write a letter
to the family the imaginary family that
died in that car wreck 20 years ago
okay
yeah i want you to imagine a name for
them tell them that you're sorry that
they died in the car
that um
you know they had hopes and dreams and
that they are gone
and you never met them but you miss them
and you're sorry that that happened
and what we're doing there is we're
connecting the fight-or-flight part of
your brain to right now
you weren't safe then you're safe now
and what we're trying to do over time is
to calm that part down that every time
you get in a car
the second thing is
when you get in the car
it would probably be good honestly if
you wrote your 20 year old 20-year past
self a letter too that acknowledges we
almost died
right so dear sherry 20 years ago we
were driving on the road man if it
wasn't for one phone call we would have
been dead
but we made it and we're okay
and that was scary right i want you and
what we're doing is we're just letting
our bodies
acknowledge that happened but we're okay
now
and then the third the second thing is i
want you to begin to look at what are
the alarms telling you about your
current ecosystem
are you exhausted when's the last time
you exercised how's your diet how is
your marriage when's the how what's your
sex life like your intimacy life
are you and your husband um pulling
apart are y'all coming together how are
you grieving the loss of your boys
their childhoodness now they're adults
right
they're gonna start kissing girl a
growth right whatever's gonna happen
it's gonna start happening you gotta
start acknowledging that stuff and i
want you to be honest about it and find
somebody you can tell if you and your
husband have a great relationship that
could be a great place
and when i've seen this done it's a
teary sob sobbing mess
because our bodies have been trying to
solve for these things but our heads are
just all right gotta go the next meeting
gotta go the next thing gotta go to
little league
and our bodies are trying to solve for
this over and over and over and over
again while our heads are just trying to
stay in the game
and then the third thing is you have to
be honest about
your job
that secondary traumatic stress i had to
transition from one job to another when
i was healing from anxiety
we took a massive household income pay
cut to do it
i had to go work with a smaller group of
students i still did the same job i just
did it with 500 students instead of 4
000.
and that allowed me
over time to heal up
and i had to start serving my local
community had to do some different
things i don't know what that's going to
be for you
i've also had seasons and i'm super
anxious and i kept my same job and
things were fine i just had to be
intentional about my boundaries at work
and not taking everything and i'm i
can't control all this stuff right
ultimately
oh and here's the fourth one you're
going to have to decide to get on the
road and acknowledge it every time you
get in the car for a season i'm about to
get in the car and i'm going to drive
safe
that's the best i can do
okay
and when your body starts to get anxious
on you before you flip out
ask yourself what are we nervous about
right now
like what's my body trying to tell me
that we're going 90 miles an hour in a
little square kia yeah that's pretty
terrifying
but i got it
you see what i'm doing i'm taking the
i'm taking the gas out of that that
anxiety engine
why why is my body doing this oh cause
that guy's driving like a [ __ ] i'm
gonna back 10 miles an hour off or i'm
going to speed up 10 miles an hour and
pass them because i don't want to be in
the vicinity of that person
oh man every time i see a tractor
trailer my heart starts beating really
fast i'm just going to get curious and
i'm going to stop going to war with my
body tell me if i'm wrong
now you've gotten to a point where when
y'all have to go somewhere you get
anxious about the fact that you're going
to get anxious
yeah yep yep
yes
we we have a trip planned and we decided
to fly because my husband nor i could
handle the drive it would be a disaster
so
ah awesome
it could have been a good time but let's
fly on this one
and then let's start practicing and this
is going to sound silly but i want you
to tell your husband um hey saturday
we're just going to go to a 30 minute
drive on the highway and i'm going to
practice saying nothing
i'm going to practice
loosening the grip on the steering wheel
or i'm going to not grab the little door
handle
while you're driving right
the emergency brake that doesn't exist
exactly my pedal i'm going to put my
feet up on the dashboard with no shoes
then i'm going to paint my toenails
while you drive
i'm going to feel
oh boy what we're doing here practice
we're just practicing not being anxious
and
in short order your body will begin to
realize oh she's driving now we don't
have to run this thing from the fight or
flight anymore because sherry's in
control
we're here when you need us the next
time some idiot drives crazy which they
will
we're ready
we're ready we'll flood you full of
adrenaline and cortisol and we'll help
you think move a little bit faster than
your brain's even thinking but until
then sherry's got this
and it's a choice i'm gonna decide to be
less anxious over time i'm gonna be
curious about it when my alarms go off
and if you're honest with yourself those
anxiety alarms go off
more so than when you're in the car
my guess is they're going off a lot
that's just a place where there's a gps
pin in your life
and it it's easy to go oh that's where
it is my guess is
there's a disconnect with your boys this
is a time of transition for your
marriage this is a time of exhaustion
from work this is a global mess we're
all dealing with it's expensive to buy
gas all those things are happening and
my guess is your anxiety alarms are
running across the board right now as
they are in lots and lots and lots and
lots of us
and it's just easy to point at the
driving that's where all surfaces that's
the volcano but it's been turning
underneath all that so what we're going
to do is we're going to work to have a
life that goes
the only word i can say here that
doesn't sound cheesy is peace
i'm just going to sleep
we're going to get our sex life back
we're going to start eating better we're
going to go for walks in the evening or
in the mornings
peace
and then your body will stop some of the
alarms just willy-nilly
and then finally
you won't hassle him about the turn
signal
let the guy drive we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to chelsea
in columbus ohio what's up chelsea
hi how are you so good how are you
i'm well thanks
um so my question today is
how do i build confidence while dating
um
and some backstory to that is that i am
31 but i have cerebral palsy i walk
independently with no assistant devices
or anything like that but i just
struggle in this one area
of life and i don't know how to fix it
okay so tell me
like tell me about you what do you do
where are you from where'd you grow up
i'm from ohio i work for the state
commerce um compliance department
i oh that's just a barrel of monkeys
it's fun i really like it my my team is
really cool did you know that did you
know in the history of the english
language no one has ever uttered the
sentence you just uttered
the compliance in whatever whatever
department is fun and i like it no one's
ever said those words ever you're like
shakespeare now that's fantastic no
that's awesome i'm glad i'm so glad you
love your your work man my buddy works
for in-compliance for the government and
he loves it and i would rather set my
face on fire just to see if i can still
feel things and so good hey somebody has
to do that i'm so grateful for you um
how'd you get this job how'd you get
into it
i well that's funny too my degree is in
healthcare administration but
right before the pandemic i just decided
to try something new
started applying for different jobs and
ended up in this agency i had worked for
other agencies that were more dealing
with the public
before that and then just kind of
stumbled upon this because i
met somebody who worked in this
department at a meeting and just kind of
liked what they had to say so i
applied for the job and got it have you
ever seen the matrix
no
well
there's a scene in the matrix just
google dodging bullets
when uh keanu reeves leans back and the
bullets fly by him that's what you just
did with the code by getting out of
public health
30 minutes before the whole thing went
down good for you man
it was so true
literally like days before where'd you
grow up
um columbus i still live where i grew up
in the same town
you said that like you failed something
do you want to go somewhere else
no i just that's all i've ever known all
right i just like it i like it i like
the commentary between it and you know i
my friends are here and i have a big i
have a
big friend group here that i really like
and
so good all right so you're delightful
um thank you i work with a lot of mean
pushy people
just kidding kelly's nice she's nice
um
but you sound delightful so tell me
about this dating mess
so i i really didn't even know that i
had a problem i i have a core group of
friends that i would say there's like
eight couples that go out constantly and
then there's me so i always joke that
i'm everybody's girlfriend
and you know we go out and it's like i
never feel like the third wheel i never
feel
like i'm not part of the group because
they've just always made me feel that
way
and
one of our waitresses one time that we
regularly get she said i couldn't figure
out who you were dating because you walk
in on somebody else's arm all the time
because we always hold hands as we walk
so that i don't fall
and things like that and she said it's
just funny she said they just love you
and i said i know
and um i won this kindness award at work
and i sent it in the group chat and i
got all kinds of um you know
congratulations and all that and then
one of my best friends he said
chelsea you're the only one who doesn't
get to experience your own kindness
you're not kind to yourself and i wish
that you were and i said oh i never
really thought about that
he said you're so kind to everybody else
i've been in 17 weddings
just yeah so i don't i don't have 17
friends that's incredible
no it's great my closet is full of these
dresses i refuse to get rid of but it's
it's great and it's a little expensive
but hey you know it's like one of those
things like i i don't struggle when it
comes to building relationships but i
struggle
when it comes to dating because i just
don't feel like i'm the one someone's
going to choose i always
say i think god blinked when he made me
but only in the dating area
it doesn't make any sense like no it
does it does it does it does you're not
crazy okay
um and my one my one promise on this
show
i'm gonna get answers wrong i might get
this one wrong but my promises always
tell the truth okay
and
um
here's i know this
that kindness often
um
people who are very very kind are often
very very lonely too
is that fair uh yeah and yeah there's
there is a relational lonely and you've
got you're surrounded by people right
there's a proximity to loneliness you're
surrounded by people
um who are sound like they're amazing
like that's you you won the lottery when
it comes to that
and then there's that
yeah see that's awesome
then there's emotional loneliness where
i can be in a crowded room
um surrounded by people who love me and
that i love and i feel completely and
totally alone
because nobody knows
i would do anything
for someone to be
looking me up and down right now i would
do anything for someone to squeeze my
hand under the table
right and i'm not going to say that out
loud because i want to bring everybody's
room down because i'm kind
and all these folks in here are really
nice and so i'm not going to i'm going
to make sure oh they're so right you
know what i'm saying is that you uh
yeah it's hard for me to admit that but
it's like you hit the nail on the head
there so
when's the last time you spoke out loud
here's what i want
and here's what i need and here's what i
don't have
because you're somebody who sees
yourself as broken
you see yourself as less than so much
that you even blame god for like ah he
whiffed on the on the assembly line
and
that's how you see yourself
and
the people around you don't see yourself
that way
but they
you when they when they don't see you
that way you put imaginary things in in
the mix
have you ever said these words well
they're nice to me because i've got
cp
or they invite me out because they don't
want me to be lonely because they're
nice
no well no they
my friends
they've been around for so long but they
don't even see it anymore like it's just
a natural thing and i want to get to
that point with somebody
in the dating
situation too and i know that i can get
there but i just i sabotage it before it
even starts
oh he doesn't like
me yeah so have you ever had have you
ever had somebody be ugly to you dating
or something weird or okay tell me about
that
so i
tried like the online thing and so
because that's how everybody meets
people nowadays and so i noticed that
when i would mention it up front
they would become very sympathetic and
just
and they wouldn't want to just go away
they'd want to talk about it but they
weren't interested in dating anymore but
then when there was one time that i
didn't mention it and i met them in
person and his reaction even though it
didn't i don't think it was his fault
but it was extremely poor because he was
so distracted by what he didn't realize
what he was getting into or something
you know so he was just so distracted by
that that he couldn't see me for who i
was so it wasn't a productive
date by any means and he just wasn't his
reaction wasn't kind
so chelsea
he was an ass not you
right
yeah
his reaction was his poor reaction it's
not a reflection of some shortcoming you
have
you're different and you're unique is
that fair
which which cp do you have like which
cat which bucket is it in
it's a
okay so and you say you just is it one
lower body
that's been basically in my legs okay
so when when somebody hears that on an
online chat
i've got cerebral palsy
a
most people don't know what that is
b
they're gonna google it and get
to webmd and we all know like i got a
headache well it's probably cause you
have a brain tumor and you're gonna be
dead in 48 hours right so yes
when somebody gets that online they
don't have a context for it okay and i'm
gonna like i'll give them grace for that
you know what that means you know what i
mean i don't know what that i don't even
know what that is um
i don't know
i i don't think you owe somebody that up
front
i also would much rather you meet
somebody in person because you're a
delightful human being and you're
surrounded by cool people
thank you it feels like is is dating
feel safer online because you're afraid
of someone
being an idiot to you
no i hate online i really do i hate it
can be super super honest with you
yes
my guess is before this crew maybe
been around forever
but
you've got a lifetime of people side
eyeing you
and or snickering or feeling exposed as
you walk through the mall or you walk
through an airport yeah
and that baggage comes with you every
time you reach out to connect with
somebody
and what it that that
those bricks in your backpack for lack
of better analogy
that stuff that's happened those side
eyes those little bitty things have been
a pebble in your backpack pebble in your
backpack some idiotic [ __ ] said
something to you in fourth grade because
they were nine
and they threw a cinder block in your
backpack you've probably got those
stories right
or some well-meaning
goofball at your church whatever has has
happened
and
all the evidence
now
points to
you are
wonderful
so much so that people would rather hang
out with you than have a romantic
rendezvous alone that's how cool you are
that's how fun you are to have around
you know what i mean even the
the waitress at the at the bar y'all
frequent think you're some kind of
player dude because you got a new dude
every time
you know what i mean well i walked in
with the girls too she wasn't sure
hey dude she's she thinks you are
you're
yeah you are playing across the field
right
so
here's the thing the evidence in your
life suggests
that people love connecting with you
and so the own and this is hard because
there are idiots and you experience them
there are people that don't know what to
say or they think they know what to say
and they say the wrong thing
that are uncomfortable around
um physical differences or
they've never been around people who
aren't fully able-bodied all those
things happen
and so there will be some grace on your
part and you probably have a pretty good
radar when someone's being an idiot or
they just don't know and someone's being
a jerk
right i mean you're pretty savvy yeah
right you can tell like don't say that
i've got friends in my life my best
rental planner is a paraplegic
i've had other people who are not able
body come up and be like yeah that may
be funny for y'all because you all know
each other for 40 years don't say that
ever in public right and so you know
when someone's being a jerk or someone's
and your friends probably get away with
stuff too right and if they're your real
friends they should okay good
um
here's what i want you to remember
that
if somebody
rejects you makes a comment does
something dumb
because of your differences
that's a sign that they are
less than not you
okay
and the only way forward
is for you to take a risk
and my promise to you is you're going to
get hurt doing this
and my promise to you is it's the only
way
you're going to finally let some of
those walls down
that bridge that gap from friend to
no you're the one i've been looking for
and the only way to make that bridge is
for you to take a risk
i'm willing to do that
and what i'm telling you is
it's um
you're worth that risk
thank you and walking around
walking around shielding yourself from
your heart from love
man you're not protecting that guy
that's going to get suckered into
falling in love with somebody who is
deficient
you're just going to keep yourself from
true connections in that way don't do
that to chelsea you're my friend don't
do that
is that fair
yes i appreciate that okay yeah so
moving forward here's the task i want
you to get with your friends
and i want you to do do you uh watch the
office
yeah do you remember that time michael
scott comes out and he's like i declare
bankruptcy
and they were all like yes that's not
really how that works remember that
that's gonna be you and i want you to
get with a core group of five or six or
ten people
and say chelsea's officially on the
prowl
and i'm gonna take risks
because i want romantic connection
period
and my guess is they'll all cheer for
you and be like oh thank god i've got
so-and-so or they may not
but i want you to declare it say it out
loud okay
okay
protecting your needs and protecting
what you want from everybody else is not
kind
it's dishonest
okay
so start telling people what you
actually need and what you actually want
and you can tell them i love hanging out
with you of course i'm coming out
but if i see him i'm leaving you guys
enough you're gonna have to uber
yourself home because right you know
what i mean
yeah
hey are you worth it
i well i hope so i think i am no
chelsea i am yes
yes
yes
and there's somebody who is
dying
for a hilarious
kind
fun
open
woman like yourself
i hope
nope no i'm gonna find them no
hey if you will just be still and open
your heart up
yeah we'll find each other
they're not hiding from you somewhere
and you're gonna get hurt and there's
gonna be idiots and there's gonna be
people who say the wrong thing and they
don't really mean it but that i didn't
mean to say it like that i meant to say
it like this and just so you know that
happens in non-able i mean in fully
able-bodied relationships too
the number of times i've said a thing
and i didn't mean to say it like that
with my wife oh gosh a lot
a lot okay
i want you to begin walking through life
seeing yourself that if somebody has the
opportunity to be with you they've won
the lottery
not they're settling for less than
okay
okay do you promise that
i will i will i promise okay homework
assignment tonight two things number one
you're gonna get the gang together it
doesn't have to be tonight you're gonna
call and get them together and say i'm
making a declaration
number two
you are going to write chelsea a letter
tonight
okay
and that letter's going to be one of
strength
and sexiness
and laughter and here's what i bring
and here's where i'm strong and here's
where somebody would be the luckiest
freaking guy on planet earth to have me
and yes i walk with a limp and they're
gonna have to hold my hand big freaking
deal
right right
it's not a big deal
well then you quit making it
i know i'm trying to convince myself and
i say it out loud enough that it's not
no it's time that you get quiet and
write yourself a letter okay
because hey here's the deal it is a big
deal you have cerebral palsy it's a big
deal
it's not something to be minimized right
and
you're still lovable
why thank you
am i just saying that i don't i don't
you're like oh well thank you as though
i just complimented your wallpaper
okay cool
same team i yes yes we're on the same
team all right if you're really brave i
want you to write that yourself that
letter and i want you to mail it to me
okay cool is that fair i will yep and if
mean things come out in that letter
write it all down get it all out there
on that paper okay
okay
and i want you
to go back to what your buddy said
i want you to start treating chelsea as
though she's worthy of being loved and
she's beautiful and she's sexy and she's
funny and she's worth the romantic
relationship cool
yes because you're the one holding you
back right now and a whole cascade of
idiotic morons on the internet but ta-da
they're holding everything else back too
right
is that fair yeah
yeah
okay you are hands down one of the most
delightful people i've ever gotten
talked to on the show and you're hands
down one of the bravest people you've
been navigating a hard hard row ahead of
you it's hard
and people don't get it
and
man
somebody is
to
talk about winning the lottery
talk about when to scratch off with you
it's gonna be pretty impressive
ah you're so great chelsea we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they wouldn't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
deloney
all right let's take uh unimas let's go
to nicole in birmingham hey nicole
what's up
hey how are you doing i'm good how are
you
good
what's up how can i help
so i was just my question was
how do i
have a relationship relationship with my
dad if my mom
won't let me
so a little bit of backstory to that
hold on hold on hold on how old are you
oh i'm 21. mom doesn't get a vote mom
doesn't get a vote i know i don't care
whatever you're about to say i don't
care
mom doesn't get a vote
it's more of i don't want to hurt her
feelings
type things she's choosing to have her
feelings hurt if you choose to love your
dad
yes
and that's a choice that you can't
manage
i know i'm cutting you off and i'm being
rude but i'm tired
all of your story and i want to hear it
but yes
you can't manage
the emotional dysregulation of the
adults in your life you can only manage
yours
yes sir okay don't say sir we're the
same age okay go so what's up tell me
the story um
so the back story is my parents divorced
when i was 13. i was a daddy's girl of
course
um
i really don't know the full true story
neither one of them will tell me the
true story i think it was a little bit
of cheating on both ends okay um
and
i just never got the full story since i
was so young
well so they divorced my dad stayed
around for a while
um and then a year later his family
lives in illinois
so he moved off to illinois
um didn't tell me just left
didn't try to make a relationship with
me or anything like that
um about six years later he reached out
and
my mom got pretty mad about it because
he didn't pay like any child support he
didn't
try to get in touch with me for six
years she was just kind of over it like
you don't need him you're fine
um and so
it's kind of been on and off for
a while now between me and him he'll try
to make a relationship and then he'll
make excuses of why he hadn't gotten in
contact with me
so that's why my mom's kind of like her
feelings are hurt type thing but of me
being 21 i'm
maybe going to get married to have kids
i want my dad and my wife
i just don't know how to do it or have
the conversation with my mom without
hurting her feelings gotcha so why do
you want this guy in your life
[Music]
i want to read it out to you okay
why do you want this guy
that abandoned
the most basic
responsibility
who figured out a way to untether
himself from one of the most important
loves of his life being his daughter
who left without saying goodbye who
didn't even bother to make sure you had
food on the table why do you want to re
and then now he's become
um kind of like a tornado dad he hops in
and then hops out and then hops in
creates a mess then hops out
and
makes a bunch of promises and then
doesn't keep them up why do you want to
make a relationship with that guy
yeah i and so that's what i can't decide
i've i've been back and forth between
you know what screw that guy i don't
need him i've made it this far without
him but then there's days and like weeks
at a time where i'm like dang you know i
really wish i had a relationship with my
dad
um
okay hold on those are two separate
things
so
this is hard okay it's hard
um
you have a fantasy in your life
about a father figure
that is different from what reality gave
you
because the real dad in your life sucks
he's lame
he hasn't shown up for you
okay
and i would say that if he was on the
phone with me i'd say that if he was
sitting right here
yeah everybody i don't know a human
being on the planet that doesn't have a
picture of a relationship with their dad
that they would love
and it sounds like you're chasing like
you have a picture of grandkids playing
with grandad and wrestling around going
to the pool and learning how to whittle
and awk whatever
and
from what you've told me that fantasy
will not happen will not come true
and so in many ways your mom's right
you're setting yourself up for
heartbreak again and again and again
you're right and so it's less about him
and more about man i wish i had this
and that gap between what reality is and
what i wish i had is grief
and it doesn't sound like you've ever
exhaled and said
because that's that line i wrote it down
you don't need him that's not your line
that's your mom's line
yeah that's what a scorned lover says
i'll i'll figure out a way to feed this
kid i'll figure out a way to love this
kid and make sure she's got clothes and
gets off to the prom all make sure that
um she's has someone read her a story at
night i don't need you
but that's not true about a little girl
and her dad because you do need him
and he left you
right
yeah and you're right about my mom she
you know
stuck by my side and made sure i had
everything that i ever needed
and would put herself in debt for me and
she has so but listen um
that's not a
when a parent leaves you
that oh i want to say this in the right
way
your mom didn't go above and beyond she
did what was right
yeah you know what i'm saying it's your
dad that went below
you know what i mean
now being a single mom holding it all
together is heroic it's it's it's almost
impossible i don't even know how you do
that i literally don't know how you do
that
um the friends of mine that have been
single moms they say you just don't have
another option you just figure it out
and you sleep you wake up 10 years later
and you know what i mean like it's it's
listening to them describe it is
harrowing so the effort in itself is
heroic
but when you step back and say man my
mom saved the day no your mom's supposed
to provide food and shelter for her her
daughter and your dad was supposed to be
there too and he left
yeah
and i want you to exhale
[Music]
yeah
because he left because something was
going on with him not because of you
yeah and it sounds like you are still
have this six-year-old or nine-year-old
little girl in your heart trying to
wonder what you did
and now maybe that i'm 21 and i'm gonna
have grandkids now maybe he'll
because you're still trying to fix what
happened between the two of you and you
didn't do it
he did yeah
yeah because the one thing that hurts my
feelings the most is i am his only
biological kid and he went off to
illinois and got married and has step
kids and does he'll post you know on
social media about doing things with
them and
you know for them and i'm like i'm your
only biological
child and you want nothing to do with me
like
i guess it's kind of a reminder like i'm
a reminder of my mom and so maybe that's
i don't that's not an excuse but
that may be what he's you know what he
sees when he sees me as my mom and he
don't like that i don't know
but
either way either way
trying to figure out figure out that
algorithm is a waste of your time
because you're a lovely person nicole
yeah and
you're worth having your dad stick
around and he didn't
now back to the original thing
i do believe with all of my heart that
people change
i've seen
people who are miserable parents turn
into good grandparents
and it takes an extraordinary amount of
forgiveness
they have to forgive themselves their
kids have to forgive them and it takes
an even more extraordinary
decision to say this isn't about us
anymore you blew that one
but you have a chance to redeem this
with my grandkids
and i'm gonna watch you like a hawk
because they're not getting hurt the way
you hurt me
but if you step up
we can we can heal this generational
mass
okay yeah because now we're playing
along we're playing a 100-year game
we're playing a 200-year game now okay
yeah
the chances of that happening are very
very very low
and you have to come in that
with this isn't gonna heal you
this isn't gonna fix that hole in your
heart
okay okay it's just not
um if he called you today and said i
screwed this up i messed up you were
beautiful and perfect and i left because
i was a mess
i'm sorry i'm gonna make this thing
right
and you look up a year or two later and
he's a totally different guy which i've
heard of happening
um
you will walk around differently okay
yeah in a good way
um but it won't be what healed you
it's because that little nine-year-old
girl will finally be let off the hook
for trying to solve a problem that she
didn't create
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to let that nine-year-old girl off
the hook now
um okay
and if your dad comes around your dad
comes around but it's gonna be because
he chose to not because you did
something different to woo him back
okay
and
you're an adult now and if you want to
make a relationship with him your mom
has a choice
she can choose to see this as yes my
baby girl needs her dad
come hell or high water she needs her
dad
yeah
and it's going to be painful and he hurt
me and he might hurt her but she's a
grown-up and so on and so forth or
she can act like a child and say well
then if you don't like that then i'm
taking my ball and i'm going gonna go
home yeah
and the temptation for you is to placate
her because well she did all these
things that moms are supposed to do and
dads are supposed to do which is feeding
clothes and make sure kids are smiling
right
and
she's the quote-unquote good parent and
so i got to keep her happy
yeah that is not your job
her job okay it's her job to make her
life filled with joy
she can be disappointed in you she could
say man that really makes me mad because
that guy pisses me off
right
she didn't get frustrated all those
things
but you get to make the choice she
doesn't get a vote because you're an
adult
okay she can have be have wisdom be like
nope i've heard it all before and you
may find out conversations that have
been going on behind closed doors for
the last 15 years that you have no idea
yeah and um or not
or maybe she who knows who knows
here's the your homework assignment okay
you ready okay i'm ready homework
assignment number one is that i want you
to write a letter to nine-year-old
nicole
okay
and i want you to let nicole know
that dad left and it's not her fault
she didn't do anything wrong
okay
yes
will you do that
i will that can be oh definitely it can
be a one page letter it can be a ten
page letter i've written both to myself
okay okay
the second thing is is i want you to
take your mom out for breakfast or for
lunch and just say i want to learn more
about my family what actually happened
would you talk to me about what happened
okay and now that you're an adult i want
you to have adult-sized conversations
with your mom and if she says absolutely
i will not say cool because she's
allowed to do that right and then you
are an adult and you get to respond you
can throw a temper tantrum and say but i
deserve to know or you can say okay cool
if you don't want to invite me into that
part if you if you don't want to let me
into that part of your life and my
family history great
and you can do the same thing with your
dad
okay you can reach out to him with
boundaries and say i want to meet you
for lunch and if he doesn't show up then
he's telling you where he is right now
not what you're what's up what you're
about that fear
that's fair okay
when are you getting married
um well
i just hope i get married soon i mean
i'm in a relationship of a year and a
half gross
great is he nice he is nice he's very
nice he treats me
very well i've been listening to your
show for about probably a month now um
and i just listen to the way you talk
about relationships and he does check
all a lot of the boxes so well if you
want me to give him a once-over have him
call the show and we'll uh i'll sit
kelly on them and we'll find out real
quick what this dude's made of
yes that sounds good
dude we should have that kelly as a part
of the show where can we just grill
potential mates
and i'll never say potential mate again
because they're not kangaroos but we
could like have potential like like
someone's thinking about getting married
we should just come up with like a
20-point checklist and just get after
him i meant oh kelly's all in that would
be so funny an awesome part of the show
um i i'll say it one more time for you
and for people listening
i am really sorry that your dad missed
your life
thank you that should not have happened
and to the dads listening out there
don't miss your kids lives
don't miss your kids lives because
they're going to wake up and be 21
wondering still what they did
and then they're going to be reaching
out and saying i want to start my family
and i had this picture of what my family
is going to look like and because you
did what you did
now i've got to redo all my pictures
and i have to grieve all this stuff okay
you're worth being loved nicole and
prom
sit down with this cat that you're about
to marry gross and
make sure everybody's on the same page
yes if we're if we're doing this we're
doing this once and we're doing this for
life and we're going to be around for
the kids
yes is that fair
all right you are awesome nicole thank
you so so much for being brave and thank
you for the call we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
hey we are back um
the show's been pretty upbeat and um
it will take a turn here and so if you
are have little ones in the room um
uh you may wanna put headphones on or
pause right now and come back to this a
little bit later um i've been out of
town and this is the first show back um
post uh uvalde shooting
there in texas
and
um you all know a couple of things about
me personally one i'm from texas it's my
hometown so home state not hometown but
my home state
um
number two
um
i ran around for a few years with police
officers and my dad's a police officer
and i spent a lot of my career in the
messy messy messy moments
after
disasters
and crisis stuff
i also have some pretty firm thoughts
that would
surprise everybody on every side of the
aisle when it comes to guns and
legislation and all kinds of stuff but i
think about that and there may be a time
for me to talk about what i think
um
but you also know that i think it's very
very important in these moments to stop
stop with the instagram post and stop
with the
big political grandstanding
stop with the
you should have and they did and you
shouldn't have all that stuff just stop
and exhale
and
acknowledge the names
of these little ones
and the adults here
as i'm reading this list i know there's
still a couple people still in the
hospital that may not make it
i also know that um i may miss one or
two and if i do i'm sorry i'm doing the
best i can with what i got um but it is
important for me one of the most
important things i learned working in
crisis was say say their name
say their name
so we're going to say their names
alexandria
10
amari 10
tess
10
jose
10 miranda 11.
maite
10 mckenna 10
xavier 10
eliana nine
leila
ten
10
jackie 10 annabelle 10
jayla 10
jc
10
usaya
9
navia 10
rogelio
10.
eva 44 irma 46 and her husband who died
of her broken heart two days later
at some point we have to look around and
say okay we gotta do something different
we have to re-imagine something
because this cannot continue
because my son is 12
and my daughter's six
and my kids are your kids
and your kids are my kids
so the families i can't breathe
to the community who showed up here
thank you
to the officers who walked in on this
who
were part of taking care of this to the
medical examiners to everybody involved
in this
disgusting evil
my heart's broken
and my only appeal to everybody
listening
is that as
this community heals and as we heal
we just stop for a second
and exhale and say
we lost a bunch of children this time
man
as we wrap up today's show man um
the local guy
um
lovely lovely guy brad paisley
lives down the road here and he wrote
this song
called when i get where i'm going and it
goes like this
when i get where i'm going on the far
side of the sky the first thing i'm
gonna do is spread my wings and fly
i'm gonna land beside a lion and run my
fingers through his mane or i might find
out what it's like to ride a drop of
rain yeah when i get where i'm going
there will only be happy tears i'll shed
the sins and struggles i've carried all
these years i'll leave my heart wide
open and i will love and have no fear
yeah when i get where i'm going don't
cry for me down here
i'm gonna walk with my granddaddy and
he'll match me step for step and i'll
tell him how i missed him every minute
since he left and then
i'll hug his neck
hug somebody today everybody we'll see
you soon
coming up on the next episode she was at
first on board with you know trying to
take control of our money and then it
started to take a turn where she said
that she didn't want to have anybody
telling her what to do with her money
you making this phone call is an act of
bravery and so i applaud you it's hard i
have 15 year old freshman notice the
last few months that he's having a lot
of difficulty
both kind of at home in school he's
generally a really mellow
easy-going kid having a hard time
keeping his grades up not participating
in class
the two words i'm going to always go
back to are connection and chaos where
does this human being feel plugged in to
the point that he can drop his shoulders
and say here i am